salut roman ça on sera mieux soit et des
boîtes vides
attention cette vidéo que provoquer des
crises d'épilepsie
mais comme vous ne savez pas pourquoi
regardez là quand même aucun il m il y
avait sûrement déjà vu ce genre de mises
en garde sur les jaquettes de mots jeux
vidéo ou au démarrage de votre console
et peut-être même que vous avez déjà lu
la notice
mais peut-être pas vous avez en tout cas
déjà entendu cette menace effrayante
jouer aux jeux vidéo pourraient
provoquer des crises d'épilepsie
alors est-ce qu'il faut jeter tous ces
jeux vidéo à la poubelle les mettre chez
easy cash de peur de se transformer en
tueur de masse épileptiques
pour répondre à cette question faut
d'abord en savoir un peu plus sur
l'épilepsie
d'abord il y en a tellement de formes
différentes que ce serait plus juste de
parler d épilepsie
mais on va essayer de faire simple dans
votre cerveau et ailleurs aussi mais
c'est pas le sujet il ya 100 milliards
de cellules dont le boulot c'est de
faire circuler l'information du système
nerveux qu'on appelle l'influx nerveux
et qu'on pourrait comparer un courant
électrique
ces cellules ce sont les fameux neurones
il arrive qu'un certain nombre de ces
neurones soit ce qu'on appelle hyper
excitables c'est-à-dire qu'ils envoient
un signal électrique comme ça tous
ensemble sans raison apparente ou juste
en réaction à une stimulation minimes et
ça met le bordel dans le cerveau un peu
comme des trolls sur twitter iggy ou un
peu comme des gens trop sensible un peu
de ram accords et des réactions
disproportionnées
le mécanisme est toujours le même mais
les causes et les façon dont ça se
manifeste sont très diverses
ce qui fait que l'épilepsie c'est pas
vraiment une maladie mais plutôt un
syndrome
c'est à dire un ensemble de signes qui
sont liées à un problème précis après
mon niveau du cerveau en l'occurrence
l'épilepsie peut être la conséquence
d'une anomalie génétique d'une tumeur ou
d'un accident au cours duquel le cerveau
a été abîmée ou privés d'oxygène on
parle d'épilepsie quand les crises sont
répétés et sa touche 500 mille personnes
en france ce qui en fait la deuxième
pathologies neurologiques derrière la
maladie d'alzheimer mais une crise
d'épilepsie
à quoi ça ressemble au juste comme on
l'a vu il y en a de différentes sortes
qui dépendent de la zone du cerveau dans
laquelle les neurones des charges de
façon inappropriée
il ya des crises partielles qui peuvent
se manifester par des troubles du
langage ou des hallucinations visuelles
auditives olfactives ou
auguste hâtives mais aussi des troubles
moteurs comme des mouvements répétitifs
d'un membre ou des troubles sensitifs
comme des fourmillements ces crises
partielles peuvent parfois évoluer vers
ce qu'on appelle des crises généralisées
qui sont de deux types
le premier est appelé le petit mal
épileptique dans lequel le patient à une
sorte d' absence pendant laquelle ils ne
communiquent plus et son regard est vide
et fixe le second le grand mal
épileptique c'est la crise d'épilepsie
tel constat représentent généralement
avec perte de connaissance et
convulsions on appelle ça une crise
tonico cloniques et les jeux vidéo dans
tout ça on n'y arrive pas mais vous les
crises d'épilepsie peuvent être
déclenchées par la fatigue le stress
l'alcool ou les drogues certains
médicaments ou des variations hormonales
notamment chez les femmes pendant les
périodes de règles par exemple mais ce
qui concerne les gamer ça s'appelle
l'épilepsie photosensible alors
attention l'épilepsie photosensible
c'est pas une maladie qui consiste à
pleurer devant des compte instagram le
préfixe grec photo ça veut dire lumière
et donc photosensible ça veut dire
sensible aux variations lumineuses chez
un épileptique photosensible les crises
sont déclenchées par des lumières
clignotantes ou scintillante avec une
fréquence dangereuses autour de 15 à 25
c'est à dire que si cette personne est
exposée à 15 à 25 flash lumineux par
minute
elle risque de déclencher une crise cela
concerne donc les jeux qui comprennent
des variations lumineuses importantes et
des images répétitives
c'est à dire pas tous les jeux les
patients atteints d'épilepsie
photosensible représente 5 % des
épileptiques et attention chez les
personnes concernées faire une crise
devant un jeu vidéo c'est un rist c'est
pas systématique
je projette 9 dias est aussi pris au jeu
et web là c'est ça vient de youtube et
tous les médias tiens j'ai du talent
mais j'aurais bien voulu parce qu'en
fait le choix d stimulation lumineuse de
ce type y en a aussi quand on regarde la
télé ou un écran d'ordinateur dans les
boîtes de nuit avec les stroboscopes et
même dans l'absolu
quand on regarde un coucher de soleil
qui se reflète dans les vagues au bord
de la mer c'est magnifique
il ya aussi certains motifs notamment
ceux en noir et blanc avec beaucoup de
contrastes comme les damiers où le strip
cible à fléchettes qui peuvent excité
des neurones un peu trop sensible au
point qu'il déclenche une décharge c'est
magnifique
bon a priori vous avez quand même plus
de chances de croiser un écran quel
qu'il soit donc on va se pencher sur
deux ou trois trucs qui permettent de
limiter les risques de déclencher une
crise d'abord ne pas se coller à l'écran
ya moins de risques à 2 m 54 50 cm de
distance ensuite joué dans une pièce
bien éclairée que la pénombre serre
facteur aggravant faites des pauses de
10 à 15 minutes sans écran toutes les
heures si vous êtes fatigué ou vous
manquer de sommeil aller dormir
alors sache mon petit romain que ce qui
va sans dire ça va toujours mieux en le
disant
1 et en l'occurrence le manque de
sommeil ça augmente vraiment le risque
de faire des crises donc ça fait deux
bonnes raisons d'aller dormir
autre chose je pense que l'épilepsie
photosensible se révèle entre huit et
vingt ans avant la première crise ya
donc des adolescents qu'ils sont sans le
savoir et d'autres qu'ils savent mais
qui joue quand même aux jeux vidéo alors
si vous jouez avec un ou une amie qui se
met à faire une crise qu est ce que vous
pouvez faire d'abord resté calme même si
ça peut être impressionnant et noter
l'heure pour savoir combien de temps
dure la crise ensuite en cas de perte de
connaissance ou de convulsions éloigner
tout ce qui pourrait blesser votre ami
enlevé lui ses lunettes s'ils
l'emportent et protéger sa tête en
plaçant quelque chose de mou en dessous
vous avez sûrement entendu dire qu'il
fallait mettre quelque chose dans la
bouche de quelqu'un qui fait une crise
d'épilepsie pour protéger sa langue et
éviter qu'ils laval est la vie
ne faites surtout pas ça vous risqueriez
de laisser un doigt ou de blesser votre
pote desserrer son col et sa ceinture
pour l'aider à respirer et placé en
position latérale de sécurité pls
c'est-à-dire allongé sur le côté pour
lui éviter de s'étouffer pour la ps vous
mais un lien dans la description on en
reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo
ensuite surveiller le sens le bouger et
sans essayer de l'empêcher de faire ses
mouvements normalement la crise doit
durer deux à trois minutes
si elle dure plus de 5 minutes ou si
votre ami arrête de convulsé mais ne
reprend pas conscience au bout de dix
minutes appelé les secours et quand il
va revenir à lui il sera pas bien un qui
est sonné calmer le rassurer le sait
bien cet endroit voilà vous avez compris
les jeux vidéo ça ne rend pas
épileptique puis ça peut provoquer des
crises chez les gens qui le sont déjà
parfois sans le savoir pour ça qu'il
faut rester vigilant voilà dtcc tout bon
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner surtout
d'ici là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]